First, they thought Andrew Tate was
going to rescue them from the avalanche
of apostasy. Let's check on Andrew
[Music]
Tate. Then they thought Sneo was going
to rescue them from the avalanche of
apostasy. Let's check on Sneo.
[Music]
Now they think Lily Jay is going to
rescue them from the avalanche of
apostasy. Let's check on Lily J.
[Music]
And how is she going to rescue them? By
recycling the same terrible arguments
that have been debunked so thoroughly,
so frequently even the da guys stopped
using them. Take the argument from
scientific miracles. Does the Quran
contain miraculous scientific facts that
couldn't have been known during the time
of Muhammad and are only being confirmed
by scientists today? That was the claim
for decades. But we went through all the
ridiculous lies and exposed them until
the Dawagandists finally admitted
defeat. I mentioned that the scientific
miracles in the Quran got debunked. I'll
repeat it again very carefully. The
scientific miracles argument in the
Quran got
debunked. Yeah, I hope my tu was on
point. Listen, it got debunked. And you
know why many people in the data minat
YouTubers my colleagues like brothers
that I work with didn't do a video. Why
did you say that? Because they know it
as well. The argument of science and
miracles debunked. It is debunked. The
hell with science. The scientific
argument of miracles in the Quran is
debunked. It is debunked and we don't
need it. You've never heard me say this
before and you'll probably never hear me
say it again unless it's about this
topic. But listen to Ali Dawa.
The argument from scientific miracles
has been debunked. The scientific
miracles argument in the Quran got
debunked.
Listen to the daagandists who were
already humiliated because of this
argument. If you don't, then what's
about to happen in this video is going
to keep happening over and over and over
again. But Lily Jay is getting paid too
much to care. So, here we go. Did you
know the Quran revealed a scientific
miracle about the ocean over 1,400 years
ago? Something that science only just
discovered recently? Let me guess. The
two seas and the barrier between them
that keeps fresh water from mixing with
salt water, which isn't even true. In
the Quran chapter 25:53, it says, "And
it is he who released two seas, one
fresh and sweet, one salty and bitter,
and placed between them a barrier that
cannot be crossed." So two seas, one
fresh and sweet like me, and one salty
and bitter, like the lies Lily J is
about to tell. And there's a barrier
between them that cannot be crossed.
That's what she said, right? It says,
"And it is he who released two seas, one
fresh and sweet, one salty and bitter,
and placed between them a barrier that
cannot be crossed." Let's read the
verse. And he it is who hath let loose
the two seas, the one sweet, fresh, and
the other salt, bitter, and hath put an
interpace between them, and a barrier
that cannot be passed. So there are two
seas. Which two seas? What are the names
of these two
seas? One of them is sweet and fresh.
The other is salty and bitter. And
there's a barrier between them that
cannot be passed.
You shall not pass.
Tell us about this amazing scientific
fact, mistruthful.
But here's the amazing part. Scientists
only just discovered that when fresh and
saltwater meet, they don't mix. Fresh
water and salt water don't mix.
Scientists only just discovered that
when fresh and saltwater meet, they
don't
mix. They don't mix. They don't mix.
They don't mix. Notice that Lily J
didn't bother to ask AI about this one.
Why? Because she couldn't get it to lie
about this. Let me ask
Grock. Do freshwater and saltwater mix?
Grock's response. Fresh water and
saltwater do mix when they meet, such as
at rivermouths or estuaries, forming
brackish water with intermediate
salinity. The mixing depends on factors
like water flow, tides, and density
differences. Salt water is denser and
tends to sink below fresh water. Over
time, diffusion and turbulence blend
them, but distinct layers can persist in
some conditions, like in estuaries with
strong river flow or in certain ocean
currents. That's strange. I thought
scientists just discovered that fresh
water and salt water don't mix. They
don't mix. There's an invisible barrier
between them that keeps them separate
called halocline, which forms between
them due to differences in chemical
composition, density, and temperature.
The only part she's right about is that
Halocline has something to do with
density and temperature. When fresh
water from a river enters the ocean, the
salt water, like Lily J, is more dense.
So, the less dense fresh water will stay
on top for a bit. But there's no barrier
that cannot be passed. As the Quran
says, it just takes a while for the
water to mix. This would be impossible
for someone without modern technology to
know. But the Quran describes it
perfectly. The Quran describes Halo
Klein perfectly. Let's read the verse
one more time. And he it is who hath let
loose the two seas. Two seas. the one
sweet fresh and the other salt bitter
and hath put an interspace between them
and a barrier that cannot be passed. A
barrier that cannot be passed isn't
haloccline at all. Is this proof that
the Quran is the word of God? What do
you guys think? Is this the proof that
the Quran is the word of God? I have to
confess I would be impressed if the
Quran accurately described
halocines. But is that even what the
Quran is talking about? Let's find out
after a brief word from this video's
sponsor. Lily Jay thinks that fresh
water and saltwater don't mix. But you
know what does mix? Your family and some
handpicked treasures from the places
where Jesus walked. Even if you can't
make it to the land of the Bible, you
can still get amazing items from
Jerusalem and Nazareth and Bethlehem and
other locations delivered to your door.
I'm talking about getting an Artza box.
Every Artza box connects you with the
Bible and is filled with items that will
bless your home. And by signing up,
you'll be supporting the local Christian
and Jewish families and businesses and
charities that create them. You get
candles, Israeli spice mixes, olive wood
carvings, mosaic art, decorations,
cosmetics, candy, games, all kinds of
things. Arts of boxes are fun to open
with your family, and they make great
gifts. There's a new box every season,
four new boxes every year. So, join
Artza and bring the Holy Land into your
home, one season at a time. The link is
in the description. Use the promo code
Bizzle to get a discount and to let them
know who sent you. Now, back to Lily J
and the miracle of the Halo Klein.
Here's what surah 25 verse 53 means
according to actual Muslim scholars.
Quran quotes are in parenthesis. The
rest is the commentary of Iben Cathir.
And it is he who has let free the two
seas. This is palatable and sweet and
that is salty and bitter means he has
created the two kinds of water sweet and
salty. The sweet water is like that in
rivers springs and wells which is fresh
sweet palatable water. This was the view
of Ibenjer and of Ibener. And this is
the meaning without a doubt for nowhere
in creation is there a sea which is
fresh and sweet.
Notice what he just said. When the Quran
says two seas, it must mean two kinds of
water because nowhere in creation is
there a sea which is fresh and sweet. So
there aren't two seas. Good to know.
Allah has told us about reality so that
his servants may realize his blessings
to them and give thanks to him. The
sweet water is that which flows amidst
people. Allah has portioned it out among
his creatures according to their needs,
rivers and springs in every land
according to what they need for
themselves and their lands and that is
salty and bitter meaning that it is
salty bitter and not easy to swallow.
Then he talks about various seas not
very important. Let's get to the
miracle. And he has set a barrier and a
complete partition between them. meaning
between the sweet water and the salt
water. A barrier means a partition which
is dry land which is dry land. Which is
dry
land. The barrier isn't a halocline. The
barrier between freshwater and saltwater
is dry land. And a complete partition
means a barrier to prevent one of them
from reaching the other. So what is the
Quran saying according to actual Muslim
scholars? It's saying that there's fresh
water over here and salt water over
there and land in
between. The land is what keeps the two
kinds of water separate.
That's true enough, but is it amazing
scientific knowledge that couldn't have
been known in the seventh century? Is
this proof that the Quran is the word of
God? What do you guys think? I'm going
to have to go with no. The Quran says
there are two seas. That's wrong. So, it
has to be reinterpreted.
Even with the reinterpretation, the
Quran is simply saying that there's land
between freshwater and saltwater, which
keeps them separate. And I'm pretty sure
people knew that in 7th century
Arabia. So, better luck next time, Lily
Jay. I hope they're paying you well to
lie to people. But you should have
listened to Ali Dawa. The scientific
miracles argument in the Quran got
debunked.
Don't get too salty now.
[Music]